oh hi everybody and welcome to the very
last episode of Game life for the year
2008 hopefully well we'll still have a
show in 2009 right yeah but anyway for
the time being 2009 Chris Baker and I
are going to talk about our predictions
for the coming 12 months all right
beggar why don't you start us off with
some of the trends that you think are
going to be really important in not in
2009 well I think the first and most
important one to talk about is a crisis
in big budget gaming sure you know as
you know yep we're seeing some amazing
games on playstation 3 xbox 360 but to
make a game that really uses those
consoles their full potential takes
teams of over a hundred people several
years yeah millions and millions 40
million dollars right the big problem
for big-budget games is they have to
earn all of that money back right away
the huge development grass the human
marketing costs because they start
looking out dated a few months after
they come out yeah and I mean this is
going to be fine for companies you know
that have sweetheart deals with
Microsoft and Sony but for independent
developers you know Baker when you when
you first brought this up you did this
the night before free radical the
developer of haze and time splitters you
know got up in the morning to find that
their office doors have been shuttered
and it's seeming like they almost might
close that company and I mean this is a
company that's been you know really
betting the farm on these big big games
and it's kind of maybe illustrating that
you know this this might be a really
risky proposition going forward unless
again you've really got you know the
financials taken care of we can expect
to see more layoffs we can expect to see
more outsourcing tiny core teams here
huge teams overseas we can expect to see
more great publishers and developers
closing down well not all great ones we
definitely expect to see the lousy ones
closing Wow Baker that's a super
depressing can we talk about something
happy now great news yeah for gamestop
ah this was a great year for the video
game retailer they make a fortune
putting games on their shelves only the
most popular games and they make a lot
of money buying them back
from people who raced through the games
and and sold them back to the stores and
then they continued to resell it and
make money off of that mm-hmm the
publishers and game developers don't see
any money off of those resole games no
they don't they don't like that they
don't like that at all and what we're
going to see more of I think we saw a
lot of in the past year but we're going
to see even more is developing games
that can be downloaded directly to your
hard drive cut out the middleman games
getting expansion packs and new levels
and new features for months and months
and months after they come out just in a
desperate effort to keep people from
selling that game back right oh and I
mean I have someone who wants to buy the
game yeah after the fat tested by a new
copy and not a used copy and that's good
for for consumers because you know it
incentivizes game makers to actually
like keep you know putting out new
content for their games that makes those
people want to keep those around but
also you're going to start seeing stuff
like you know how rock band two came out
this year and you got 20 free
downloadable songs but it was only if
you bought the game brand new then you
could use the one-time use code that was
on your instruction book you buy wrecked
been to use you don't get those free
songs we're gonna see a lot more of that
you know between digital distribution
and just sort of giving people these
incentives to buy these games new just
in an attempt essentially to kind of cut
that used game market out of the
equation and what we're also going to
see you know retail isn't going away of
course it's a big factor but we saw with
games like gears of war two was they
were available for sale at 7-eleven
which does not buy back to his games and
miraculously they showed up for sale
early there a few days before they went
on sale at the big game stop chain so
this is a conspiracy theory Baker the
truth is out there
this is going to be a great year for
geeks who code in their underwear in
their garage all right yes indie gaming
games made by very small teams of just
one or two people were starting to be a
big story last year with little braids
made by just a couple of people yet
world of goo made by a two-man team
garnered you know all the critical
acclaim of a triple a big-budget game
and actually found an audience and made
a little bit of money I hear a lot of
people saying it's sort of like 15 years
ago when we saw the indie film movement
a lot of people saying mm-hmm just a few
guys with the camera made something
that's fresher and more engaging than
anything saw in Hollywood would this
year I think the same thing is happening
in games I think we're gonna see is not
so much you know video gamers on mass
playing games like braid and totally
ignoring Gears of War 3 what I hope
happens is that the makers of these big
budget games that publishers will kind
of look at things like braid and say
okay you know what we don't have to
whitewash our big budget game we we
don't have to you know let marketing
control the content of the game we can
have a singular creative vision drive
our game and that'll be okay people will
accept that I think the landscape is
starting to splinter it's becoming more
like video sometimes you want to watch a
beautifully produce movie on DVD
sometimes you want to watch a silly
half-hour sitcom sometimes you want to
watch a two-minute clip on YouTube and
now games have that sort of range of
experiences available to people and you
can play whichever you feel like at that
moment okay Baker thanks for that
depressing roundup of 2009 friends now
for my depressing roundup of what
nintendo microsoft and sony are going to
do in 2009 now Nintendo we've already
gotten a glimpse into their first three
months of their game lineup and it's a
yeah it's about is about as barren as
that these past few months have been for
wii owners in fact only bringing out two
games and they're both ports of GameCube
games Mario power tennis which is going
to use wiimote controls now for the for
the tennis swinging and pikmin which is
going to use the pointer to throw your
if your Pikmin all over the place now
both of these sound like a lot of fun I
think it's a great idea bringing these
GameCube games back
wider audience the thing is I kind of
wanted them to you know supplement the
wii's release lineup like how we were
supposed to be getting punched out and
sin and punishment and those aren't
coming out until at least like April so
we all kind of get to sit around and
content ourselves with seven year old
games the only thing I can think is that
they are holding a lot of games back to
implement that wii motionplus control
and yeah I heard about it at the last
III and then of heard nothing since
right yeah they've been totally silent
on wii motionplus and i think it's i
think this is key like i think this is
one of their this is their big thing for
2009 just like we fit was their big
thing 408 you know we motionplus getting
this little adapter into the hands of as
many wii owners as they can with as many
big games as they can is their big push
just like we saw with you know the wii
board and the wii zapper before it you
know third parties lined up to have
games ready so i would expect maybe
they'll even push motionplus back past
the new you know 40,000 person III
they're gonna have in 2009 so it can
have a big coming-out party you know so
they can get as many titles as they
possibly can i don't think we're going
to see like metroid with motion plus
anytime soon like this year because i
think that what retro is doing right now
is working on metroid prime one and two
you know the gamecube games again
rehashed with wii controls maybe those
who use motion plus who knows but that's
going to be a big big part of nintendo
strategy in 2009 i think we'll also see
a lot of japanese game developers
committing to the wii they are you know
for all the reasons when we were talking
about the big budget games on all the
reasons we cited they're very ill
equipped to make games and actually make
money off of ps3 and xbox 360 and we've
seen the latest Dragon Quest announced
for Wii and that's always you know a
weather vane you know where where that
goes a lot of games go yeah now that
dragon quest 10 is officially on the way
you're going to see Japanese publishers
making a lot more of a commitment to
that platform because they know you know
that the audience is going to be there I
bet we're also going to see at least one
more announcement of a Japanese game
developer partnering with a Western game
publisher like you know when suda51 and
grasshopper than no more heroes
guys partnered up with Electronic Arts
which is almost unheard of essentially
for a Japanese publisher to do that but
I mean that's where the money is that's
where the the actual cash is to you know
they can actually make games that they
want to make yes so we've seen Microsoft
they've come out with this this much
cheaper console they've also come out
with a lot of games designed to appeal
to casuals games that are very similar
fishs Lisa more need a Sony's game right
seen it you've got seen it you've got
your in the movies which is like I toy
you've got lips which is like singstar
and all of these seem designed maybe not
to steal Nintendo's thunder but to stop
anyone who's a casual gamer from buying
a PlayStation 4 you give them no reason
to get a playstation 3 yeah they're not
they're not copying wii sports they're
not copying we fit they are copying
singstar and buzz and all of that kind
of stuff so yeah interesting III do
think though that were past the point in
the xbox 360's life cycle where
Microsoft would introduce any kind of
you know big new strategy I don't think
we're gonna see a motion controller this
year you know I don't think we're gonna
see like a blu-ray add-on drive or
anything too crazy I think that they've
they've gotten themselves kind of set in
stone with what they're going to do for
the rest of the 360's life and it's just
you know keep bringing out good content
keep getting the price down one more
prediction I think Microsoft's
partnership with Netflix could turn out
to be a very very big deal yeah you know
in the last console generation people
talked about how the fact that Sony's
PlayStation 2 was also a DVD player just
at the point when DVDs were breaking em
ended up being a huge selling point and
the PlayStation predominated that
generation of game consoles now anyone
who buys an xbox 360 and has a netflix
account and a broadband connection
pretty much has video on demand in their
home and I think as more and more people
become aware of that that's going to
become a really big differentiator I
know a lot of people who are just
surprised to find themselves logging in
and just watching a TV
show that they're downloading to their
Xbox rather than play a game right yeah
and I mean I you know the console war
might come down to uh you know digital
downloads of movies or streaming movies
versus buying movies on blu-ray in which
one ends up you know ring true with
consumers speaking of blu-ray moving
right along to our friends at Sony
here's my crazy prediction for 2009
alright this is this is the the nuts 1f
in brand new III okay this year 40,000
people are going to be their eyes of the
world on Sony wondering what it is
they're gonna do I can see Sony
potentially announcing and even showing
the PSP to at this point they've got
very little to lose you know with with
the PSP it's kind of coming back you
know Sony is now seen as being maybe a
bit more of a player in the portable
video game wars but PSP one isn't really
going to go anywhere against the d/s and
I think that Nintendo content to
essentially rest on their laurels
bringing out the dsi which is a d/s with
new features Sony could come in and have
the PSP to and actually maybe get some
people excited they've really got to let
people play it though they can't just
talk it up at e3 if they want to talk
about it because that's kind of what got
them into this mess in the first place
you know the problem they've had all
along with the PSP is it's so
sophisticated that you need huge
development budgets to actually make a
game to take advantage of it you know
meanwhile on the d/s there they're
spending you know a few months to make a
game like brain age and you know they
send it out there and it sells 1520 some
ungodly number of copies yeah and if it
doesn't work they haven't wasted that
much money you know I think a new better
piece of hardware isn't necessarily
going to rescue that platform I mean the
hardware has been selling well for a
while it's if the d/s weren't just a
juggernaut we'd all be remarking how
well the PSP is selling but software
just isn't moving yeah hardware wise
it's like I think it's the most
successful product right now so yeah
2009 guys pay attention to the portable
gaming Moore's d SP SP iPhone and who
knows what else I think that's one of
the really interesting things that might
happen this year oh and just one more
thing there's one platform we haven't
mentioned
yet I think in a lot of ways the hottest
platform of 2009 won't be the way won't
be the 360 won't be the ps3 in his mondo
engage flakes is a clever but no no it
will be your web browser we've been
seeing an explosion of games in the last
year of that were available through
Facebook that were available you know a
simple flash games we've seen even
massively multiplayer games that play
out only inside of browsers you know you
if you don't know anyone under 12 assam
about Club Penguin right right right you
know habbo hotel because like this are
just getting bigger and bigger and
bigger they're kind of under our radar
they're they're not our sort of games
but I think they I think they will
increasingly be in the year to come well
that about wraps it up for the year 2008
happy holidays everyone and if everyone
could do me a favor do not watch this
video again in december two thousand
nine and see what we were wrong about
these now and mock us in the comments we
get enough of that already thanks for
being here we did the same for you we
you